hot breath you're gonna get famous three
ways
if you're interesting you're you have a
big personality
because that helps a lot if you're a big
personality and you're funny you're
gonna be a star
because a lot of people say man if i
just get on joe rogan that's
it no that ain't gonna be it
if you're not a talker like me i'm
talking right now in his podcast
now if i'm waiting for him for the for
the host right here to ask me another
question and then i just give a lame
answer or a short answer how far are we
gonna get
we're gonna go through this podcast in
two hour one hour and we're not gonna
get nothing out of it
so you don't talk if you have a problem
speaking
in public to people after a show if you
have a problem hanging out
joe rogan's podcast mark maron
um your mom's house none of those are
going to help you
because you don't got it you you don't
have the it factor
you know there's a lot of people out
there who don't have the ed factor who
still become
popular because they do other stuff you
know they
they write a screenplay or they do
something else
to help your career it's a company
stand-up company now in 2019
you can just quote jfk ask not what
comedy can do for you but what
you can do for comedy
and like now ask what the country could
do for you and what the world you could
do for the country the country's already
here
comedy is already here bro booming what
can you do
you know what are you gonna bring
different
whoo just mic drop on that one
for real that's facts yeah
like you guys call me like oh i like
there's some comics out there who are
like
who are like the norm you know like
gerald carmichael
probably don't have an instagram or a
twitter right or
or a facebook yeah but you're not jerome
carmichael
he had the juror when you had he had the
gerard carmichael show when he had a
twitter
then he got rid of it right he never had
it
no he never used it he never used it i
don't think he was ever see he's an
exception okay i know you're gonna think
how about this guy he's an exception the
guy writes
every day he made the right connections
and
you didn't what was the third you said
the three ways the comic
can get famous you said be interesting
have a big personality
and what's the third i think you said
there was going to be there were three
um hotels be nice to everyone
boom gratitude bro
hot breath